Oh Hilary a big loser Trucy loss that's
a fact but it is true we at Fox News do
love some Hillary because she's in the
news even though she lost and it's
because she lost that we're now finding
out more about her campaigns dirty
tricks this is a side benefit of Trump's
win the renewed reporting keeps turning
over rocks when we keep finding Hilary
and her cronies and who's turning over
those rocks
it's the hill newspaper The Washington
Post and yes even Mother Jones
that's not Fox and Friends and it's news
that the lurid dossier was paid for by
the Clinton machine collusive offspring
birth by Democrats and Russians than
obscured by layers of outright lies ha
that's good the real issue is that this
dossier was a big part of the
justification for molars probe so they
paid for a shady dossier got an
Independent Counsel out of it and now
they're getting indictments from that
independent counsel that are unrelated
to the dossier at this point they paid
to get manna for I indicted for stuff
that's unrelated to the election
hilarious when we have known that at
Hilary one doubted but let's not forget
that the person spending the most time
on Hillary is Hillary her blame everyone
but me tour keeps going she's the
Energizer Bunny in a pantsuit if she was
like that before the election maybe she
would have had that slightly closer
residence she had been wishing for now
mm-hmm well you know Dana I went over
the list of people that I've invested at
it's not Fox News we don't run mother
jones although sometimes i'd like to
well you know if they have a good story
you might do it i do think that so like
on the left any development in this
russia and investigation has been called
the smoking gun proves yeah that donald
trump is definitely had definitely
colluded with the russians but the but
and the opposite is true right when
anything there's brought up about
hillary the right says this is absolute
proof that she was dirty and she was the
one so i think that's why it's if they
can keep the integrity of the
investigation then that would be the
best thing for america just to get it
done let the chips fall where they may
the facts are what they are and then we
can just
move on with our lives mm-hm you know
want she's making fun of us about
talking about her but she's everywhere
she's as visible as Trump is on that
book tour I turn on the TV she's staring
at me sometimes the TV's not even on but
I think that the right just they make
her like bigger than life look at how
big she is back to me because it's so
it's striking Nancy Pelosi yeah used to
be like you know the whipping boy and
now it's Hillary Clinton but you know
the reality is that even before the
dossier Ygritte
we knew that Russia and the government
the United States government was
investigating Russian interference in
the election but you know when Hillary
Clinton complains and then I turn on and
I see people saying uh lock up Hillary I
think well maybe she has a point I know
she has the Hillary attacks Fox and look
at how it's like I don't know you know
Jessie I gotta say by the way I'll admit
it I enjoy to eat segments on her
because it's a comic relief you seem
more cheerful I am I'm very happy she
makes me happy yeah she's the other
woman is she president cuz she's in the
news every single day last week all he
did was talk about her because he was
throwing up smoke in anticipation of
Monday's indictment I know but she
that's what you think but she's talking
about him he's talking about her it's
back and forth
it's norms of reciprocity they're just
sharing back and forth with one another
Jessie I want to play this this is a
sound on tape that's what we call it in
television it's a Kellyanne Conway on a
show on the morning on Fox called Fox
and Friends you might have heard of it
does OK in the ratings talking about
talking about HRC look we would be happy
to stop talking about Hillary Clinton of
the campaign we dispense with her a year
ago but she just won't go away people
are covering her book like it's not not
fiction and and they keep talking about
what happened a year ago in these
campaigns Jessie's I mean Hillary's like
the boxer that won't leave the ring on
the fights over and she's still out
there throwing punches of course we're
going to cover that and Hillary making
an impeachment joke a little bit on thin
ice there Hillary last present
that was impeached was your husband in a
certain way I think she likes that Fox
covers her the way we do because it
makes her feel relevant without Fox
doing it there'd be no buzz because
there's something to talk about no but
you know when Hillary points her finger
at Fox you know she's guilty and that's
a signal to her friends in the media to
look the other way and cover the
treatment of her on Fox as partisan and
not serious all right on that note